Hun's kuba here disguised as a Flula Borg at the roasting of Bruce Willis aka John McClane not certain when he changed his name
I'm going to speak with visitors of this roasting and find out whether all my detonators
Give me some tips of how I can defeat him. Finally. I think you can only defeat him with words words
So write a haiku, you know, don't go after his
Waterfalls, it's all about the eye contact and the list, you know, this throws action here is off. Everybody knows that that's a confusion
So I should say confusing
But stronger kung fu film film, yes, exactly. Luckily he's getting very old
Age ain't nothing but a no age is actually important, you know, he's often barefoot
So I'd put a lot of obstacles on the ground tell that he lives in air ducts
So I would just pump a lot of gases through those ducts and you know take his wife. Are you guys friends now?
Have you been able to wrap things up? I sent him to MySpace page requests. Just nothing
How can the same witch happen to the same guy twice
I think it's actually five times now, you know, that's what life is it's just like the same
it over and over so
I
Hope I never like have to do this again. You know, we're out the detonators
Where am I definite us who they're hidden in the gimps outfit?
I'm pretending to know what you're talking about because I literally have never seen any of his films here
Is that what you wanted me to do? And that's the
Detonator. Oh, here it is. That's not what is this? What is this Trapper Keeper?
my detonators are up bearish that's with a
You